[Music]
you may have seen this chart since the
start of the corona virus pandemic in
one image it appears to capture the
state of each nation's battle in the
global war against the virus but like
all data visualizations its design tends
to emphasize some things and hides
others so here are four things we need
to know to understand this chart first
this is not a chart of all coronavirus
cases it's only showing us confirmed
cases that means each line doesn't just
reflect the state of the outbreak in a
country but also how aggressively that
country is testing people for the virus
take a look at japan in south korea
earlier in the pandemic japan's outbreak
looked pretty small in comparison but
the available data on testing shows us
that South Korea had tested vastly more
people than Japan did even though their
population is less than half as big and
now as Japan slowly increases their
testing the outbreak there looks more
worried it's a good reminder that we
can't understand case data without some
sense of the testing levels and that's
especially true for lower income
countries where we know their testing
capacity is limited the second thing to
know is that the scale for the y axis on
this chart is a bit different from most
charts it's called a logarithmic or log
scale on a typical linear scale you
divide the space by adding the same
value over and over the log scale is
made by multiplying a value in this case
10 100 times 10 is a thousand times 10
is ten thousand times 10 is a hundred
thousand that means that there's no
fixed amount of space on this chart for
a certain number of cases so the first a
hundred thousand cases take up this much
space and then the next 100,000 cases
get just this much
the higher the numbers the more visibly
squished they become on a log scale so
why do it this way well let's take the
five countries with the largest
outbreaks right now and rewind them back
to March 17th on a linear scale it looks
like things were pretty bad in Italy but
the others were doing better the log
scale offered a much clearer warning we
were all on the same path of exponential
growth it's the nature of infectious
disease that numbers get big fast so it
makes sense for numbers to get big fast
on the chart to fast forward a few weeks
and the linear scale shows cases
climbing and climbing while the log
chart shows curves that are flattening
as government's have implemented lock
downs and social distancing the virus is
spreading at a slower rate than before
which isn't very visible on a linear
scale but keep in mind that the
difference between this dot and this dot
is more than 32,000 people and the log
chart tends to downplay just how many
more confirmed cases there are in the
u.s. than in the other countries which
brings us to the third thing to know
about our chart it doesn't account for
population size when you adjust for
population really small countries like
Iceland and Luxembourg appear to have
the biggest outbreaks for their size
which may reflect higher testing rates
the US and China have much bigger
populations so their curves drop a bit
but the size of a country doesn't really
affect the growth rate of its cases and
it doesn't tell us much about how much
the country is struggling it just pushes
smaller countries up on the chart and
tends to hide the fact that the outbreak
is especially bad in certain regions of
bigger countries like the state of New
York
and the last thing to know about our
chart is that the x axis doesn't plot
time by the date but by the number of
days since the country recorded 100
confirmed cases for Italy that was
February 24th for turkey March 19th when
they're all layered on top of each other
it allows us to compare the trajectory
of the outbreaks but it tends to obscure
the fact that the pandemic hits some
countries before it hit others the world
watched as tens of thousands of cases
appeared in China
then big outbreaks in South Korea Italy
and Iran sent a message about what was
to come
two weeks after South Korea reported its
100th case the United States did the
same in a situation where actions taken
early could have a much bigger impact
than actions taken later time is a
crucial factor and we have to remember
that some governments had more time than
others
[Music]